- So John, when our nation was founded
there was media.
It was essentially newspapers.
How has the evolution of media affected
the evolution of political discourse?
- At the beginning of our country
the editors of the rival newspapers,
there was no middle of the road newspaper,
you were either for one or the other,
you were either a Federalist
or you were the Jeffersonian
Democratic Republicans,
as they called themselves,
and the editors were at each
others throat so violently,
they would sometimes get
in fights in the street
and knock each other down.
And you had lawmakers who were supposed
to be men of virtue as
all men in those days
would be leaking documents.
Alexander Hamilton,
the Treasury Secretary,
and Thomas Jefferson,
the Secretary of State,
would leak documents to
their favorite papers
in order to attack the other.
And eventually George
Washington had to come in
and say knock it off fellas,
because this isn't good for the country.
So the bitterness carried out in the press
was with us from the founding.
What changed over time is
that it became interestedly,
newspaper particularly, to
appeal to a larger audience.
That means you didn't want
just the left or the right.
You wanted both.
So that created a tradition,
along with a few other things,
where there was an attempt
to give just the facts,
a kind of middle of the road perspective.
We are changing from that now,
where the economics of covering the news
and the digital change
where you now can have
anybody speaking and
gaining access to the public
has created a situation where you have
a more partisan press now,
and we're in the middle
of trying to figure out
where that's going next.
- This is interesting
because a lot of people
when they talk about well,
not it's getting polarized
and partisan, the good ol'
days when you got the truth,
the wisdom from Walter
Cronkite or whoever,
but what you're really
talking about is maybe
what's going on now is a
little bit of a reversion
back to where we started.
- That's right.
In terms of the partisanship of the press
it is a reversion towards
the early days of America,
and in terms of the partisanship
of the individual members
of Congress or of the White House.
What is a little bit different
is that the call to virtue,
which would snap people
out of their partisanship,
is still up for grabs.
The founders, when they
fought like cats and dogs
during the early years
of the administrations,
Thomas Jefferson was best
friends with John Adams,
and essentially then
hired a newspaper writer
to undermine Adams when he was president.
I mean, this was a very dirty pool.
The argument they were making
was our country is new,
and what is at stake is the very survival
of the American experiment.
So they were fighting for real stakes.
They weren't just trying
to primarily keep power.
They were really trying
to make this flower bloom
that they had just planted.
So now the question is
what role does virtue play
in the American experience
to pull people away
from their partisanship?
To make them work together
for common interests?
And what is that shared
area of common interest?
What pulls them away from,
what the founders knew,
people would behave like dogs
sometimes, but they thought
they could pull away
if they thought about the common interest.
Well, is that pull still there?
- So there's a lot of talk
these days about polarization
of the media or polarization
of politics in general.
How much of it do you
think is due to things
like social media, or do
you think it was inevitable?
- We've always had polarization
in American politics,
but there was a dose of something else,
which was a call to a
higher American ideal.
And also voters would vote on
people based on their virtue,
on their larger than life statesmanship,
which was not partisan.
So you had to keep a balance.
If you were being highly partisan,
you kinda did it in quiet.
What's changed now with
social media and also
with the flood of money
in politics is that
it has encouraged people to
be more and more partisan.
The louder and hotter I
talk on a specific issue
the more money I'm gonna be able to raise,
the more interest groups
are gonna like me,
and the more clicks I'm gonna get
because I'm the one making
the most flamboyant noise.
The problem is that means the arguments
are always containing flamboyant noise.
And the people who want a calm
steady measured conversation,
well, they're not getting
read on social media.
They're not in charge
of the interest groups
that pay millions and millions of dollars.
So the system encourages
people to stay apart,
and that's one of the biggest challenges
Secretary of Defense, James Mattis,
says it may be the greatest
threat to American democracy,
that polarization.
- Do you see a way of
this getting resolved?
Or does it get worse?
Does it get better?
- There have been periods
of American history
where we have been this split.
Obviously the Civil War was
a period of great rending
in the American fabric.
What changed it was an actual conflict.
So that, God forbid,
would be one way to do it.
Another would be if there
was a threat to America
from outside its borders
and people would feel
an acute sense of national
pride and patriotism.
But other than that there doesn't appear
to be at the moment a quick fix for what
is a complicated problem
for why the two parties
have gotten into a inescapable fight
that they can't seem to
get themselves out of.
- It's like we need a
shock to remind ourselves
how much commonality there is
so all of the polarizing
quibbling goes away,
or at least gets covered up a little bit.
- Big changes in American history
usually happen from a shock and it's what
breaks people out of their behavior,
and also which tells a lot of the people
in the rest of the country
who don't participate
in presidential elections
and don't participate
in congressional elections,
it reminds them that
something real is at stake.
And there is a vast group of Americans
who really want solutions in the middle,
who don't care about the
bickering and the ideology.
But a lot of them don't
participate in politics.
And so the kind of shock
that would make people
behave who are partisans
is also the kind of shock
that would draw in people
who are just apathetic
and not participating
in the political system.